hey friends welcome back to the deep
dive snippet in this little clip i'm
speaking to karma medic who is a
youtuber and also a full-time medical
student at king's college london and
he's approaching 1 million subscribers
on his youtube channel which he's very
much grown as a complete side hustle
while being a full-time medical student
and in this little clip we are talking
about tips for new and aspiring
youtubers so i hope you enjoy the clip
so i was uploading videos every single
week for about a year and a half and i
think at that time i had 7 000
subscribers 6 000 something like after a
year and a half after a year and a half
after making like 75-ish videos one a
week for 18 months yeah yeah it's like
good amount of seven thousand six
thousand subscribers yeah yeah yeah
exactly um and then i posted a vlog
about me studying uh for a medical
school exam and that really blew up at
the time and that got like hundreds of
thousands of views within a couple of
days and then weeks um and brought i
think like 30 000 subscribers to the
channel or something like that and
that's where i felt like i had my big
break or whatever oh um okay so it
sounds like
the you know i've i've been doing a lot
of research on motivation these days for
the book that i'm working on um a lot of
uh a lot of the research suggests that
uh motivation is not a thing that you
generate before doing an action
motivation is the thing that comes after
you do the action and you see some small
level of success
and so for you it's like i'm gonna make
the video and then you're out there
hustling trying to get an individual one
at a time to watch that video that
person is giving you feedback and being
like this video was sick and then that
that gives you the the kind of dopamine
hit to continue making the videos yeah
at the same time as you're making the
videos you're personally having fun
because just the act of creation i think
is an inherently rewarding experience
right for anything you know making a
pottery
wheel thingy or making a youtube video
or writing anything there's something
about creation that really i don't know
fulfills the soul in some capacity like
yeah you can say look i made that i made
that thing yeah it was just like it was
nothing and then i turned that footage
into something good
um and i guess
those like more
uh yeah
qualitative
markers of feedback qualitative drivers
kept you going even while the numbers
weren't necessarily like incredibly high
for sure and
you know the thing that i say to people
is if you just make a video every week
for two years and try and get a little
bit better like 100 guarantee that your
life will change i can't tell you when
it's gonna happen i can't tell you what
which video is going to go viral how
many views or how many numbers how many
how much revenue how many subscribers
you're gonna get yeah and i can 100
guarantee it will change your life yeah
whether it's in terms of like the skills
you learn or the people that you meet or
you know potentially at some point a
video might pop and now we're talking
yeah the youtube game is honestly 100
consistency i really think it's just
about doing the same thing over and over
again over a long enough period of time
until something happens someone notices
your video the algorithm notes is your
video whatever
but i just really think it's about
repetition repetition repetition
yeah so okay on that so on that note um
we all we we do often sometimes get
students in our in our youtuber academy
who
uh you know take the consistency mantra
to heart
all right cool i guess i'm just gonna
make videos and then make videos about
random topics talking about things that
they're interested in filming it with
crappy quality because there's like
consistency and improvement over time um
and
one one view that i've been thinking
about a lot recently is that consistency
alone is not the answer like there are
like other ingredients that go into
success
so for you and i guess if you were
giving advice to
i don't know like
people thinking of starting a youtube
channel or potentially like
having started a
something to do with content on social
media what are the elements other than
consistency that you think feed into the
success equation yeah as it were
um
yeah i think i should probably rephrase
that consistency is a necessary
requirement whilst you're also
constantly trying to evolve and learn
and improve
consistency has to be there throughout
but as you said you're right it's not
enough um i think the main things
i mean youtube's also partially a game
you need to make content that people are
wanting to watch you need to make
content that you think is clickable that
might be shareable the algorithm might
pick up etc
and also that is
good to whatever the good standard is
and i think on youtube there definitely
is this sort of minimum
sorry there definitely is this sort of
minimum threshold of good and once
you've ticked that box it becomes less
important how good the video is right
the production quality once it reaches a
certain level anything past that is just
like okay well this is this is nice but
he doesn't need to be here you know
um
and so yeah the other things to kind of
focus on for me was just with every
video that i put out i wanted to do
something new and learn something
different whether that was a new
transition
i don't know adding music or a sound
effect or i don't know learning how to
crop in add text manipulate things um i
just wanted to do something new and you
know part of that was what made it so
intellectually stimulating to keep on
going every single week because it was
really fun as we said before
um
we are consistency and constantly trying
to innovate and get better whatever get
better means uh you know incrementally
for you over time like how do you how do
you think about this this question of
like
what what videos should i make next
okay
so
the videos that i make next are ones
that
i want to make and then they need to
appeal to who i think my niche is or my
target audience so
there's a lot of videos that i upload
that i know from the get-go are gonna
tank in terms of like numbers uh
comments views whatever
but they're videos that i think are
important and i think for the few people
who do watch it it is going to be
valuable
and so if it meets that threshold then
the video is going to get made
um and obviously there's like a long
list and we move them back and forth all
the time and there's a balance of what's
going to go out next but um yeah i need
to think that i'm going to enjoy making
this video and that there's gonna be
some value for the people who watch it
and then after that it becomes about um
it becomes more about how do we frame
this in a way that's clickable that
people will want to watch um etc
as opposed to starting from
what's the most clickable what do people
want to watch
it's a bounce it's not so black and
white
so
okay so let's say you
decide you want to do a video exploring
your menswear wardrobe because you think
it's a sort of video that would have
would appeal to someone like me
but it's not really within your core
focus of your channel to be doing
menswear content
would you do the menswear video
following this formula of like i think
this will be valuable to some people
like ali who needs menswear advice or
would you be like oh it's it's not
sufficiently valuable to the people that
i think are following my channel ie
maybe medics maybe students like
whatever uh sort of
pseudo avatar you have in your mind and
therefore i'm not gonna do the menswear
video
no i don't think so i would i would
still do the menswear video
if i want if i thought it was going to
be fun okay and it wasn't going to be
the biggest lift as you would say
um
i mean this is kind of like when i made
a 20 minute video about coffee and i was
just like drinking coffee from five or
six different methods of like grinding
the beans or whatever i made a video
about um how to publish academic
research which like is very pretty yeah
um what else have i done how to take a
patient history i did recently which you
know my channel is about medical school
studying yeah um
medical educational video yeah
meta medicine video yeah um so you know
i knew it wasn't going to do well in
terms of like numbers and algorithm but
i was like this is a valuable video that
i wish i had when i was in my first and
second year i think it'll be fun to make
let me make it hey friends thank you so
much for watching if you enjoyed this
clip then click here for the full
unedited episode and if you like that
then do please consider subscribing to
the channel it means a lot thank you so
much and have a great day